it's always nice to get packages in the
mail and this one is from book
depository
so i've got a pretty good idea of what
this is this is something that i've been
looking forward to having my own copy of
for quite some time
let's check whether i'm on track or
mistaken or not and then i'll tell you
why this book is so particularly
important if i've actually predicted the
right book
so
let's see what we have
yeah there we go it is margaret
stoicism
and emotion very nice cover there isn't
it so this is a copy of a text that i've
had a copy out from the library for
quite some time
and then it got recalled i need it for
my
own research i actually worked through
this entire text with a
client and developed writing prompts and
all sorts of other cool stuff
so let me tell you those stories in just
a moment first i'm going to tell you why
this is such an important work for me so
this is like the definitive work on the
topic of stoicism
and the emotions it's not the only work
out there there are plenty of academic
articles
and plenty of books that discuss the
emotions in a stoic perspective but
this is really like the gold standard
right
and it's uh you know it's it's
margaret graver so a great scholar
on stoicism and hellenistic philosophy
in general a translator i got to meet
her briefly at stoicon
back in toronto in 2017
great conversations with her i've
interacted with her a few other times
and this is the sort of book that
when you read it as a scholar you say
man i wish i could have written this
book because it is so good so it's got
these uh that's right nine chapters to
it
and it's really well
organized it's not just very competent
and well researched and well thought out
it brings up some
really interesting questions topics
sometimes even conundrums right so it
begins with a science of the mind the
pathetic syllogism
vigor and responsibility feelings
without a sense these are all chapter
titles right brutishness and insanity
traits of character the development of
characters city of friends and lovers
and then there's the final chapter the
tears of alcibiades if you know who
alcibiades was he was sort of like the
bad boy of ancient athens
not a person who had a lot of control
over his emotions and then there's this
really interesting
appendix the status of confidence tauros
in greek in stoic classifications that
is is like
extra material that didn't quite make it
into the chapters but really needed to
be discussed
extensively footnoted i mean this
these are the notes
and then we have a bibliography so you
can tell how much of the book is
actually like deep deep end notes
great bibliography here it's well
indexed and so again the definitive work
on stoicism and emotions now why did i
need to have a copy of this book besides
the fact that it's cool to have you know
stuff on hellenistic philosophy and
stoics so i use this pretty extensively
in my own work
on stoicism and not just the emotions
but a number of other topics
i had a copy
from the marquette library that i've had
out for about three years and i just
kept renewing it because i had
what's called a courtesy appointment
think of it sort of like you're a
professor in town and they want to
recognize you and make it possible for
you to use the research libraries
holdings and nobody else was requesting
this book
but there was kind of a snafu and things
got mixed up in terms of my courtesy
appointment and all of the books that i
had out all 16 of them most of which
were on stoic philosophy
got recalled and so i got this email
from a librarian saying you got to bring
all these books in buddy and so i did
and we
we went through them and i was like i
need these for my research
um i don't know if this is going to get
fixed anytime soon we really pro we
probably need to buy our own copies and
so i got some alexander vaphredesius
and some simplicius and
a book by cicero the on the moral ends
that i also had out and then this is one
of the ones this is the last one to
arrive
from that batch and now that i've got it
i don't have to take it out from anybody
else i've got my own
copy if i ever run into margaret graver
again in the flesh i'll ask her to sign
it for me
i will mention that i have a student a
tutorial student that several years ago
i worked through
the entire book line by line with
because he really wanted to understand
it and i said this is a really great
great text
and so i highly recommend it to you it
is written in an academic fashion but
graver
writes in a way that's pretty accessible
for non-academics
and she provides good examples which is
very important
and
you know i think if you're interested in
stoicism or you're interested in the
emotions even if you're not interested
in stoicism in particular
this would be a book that you would want
to check out because there's so many
insights that she is bringing to the
fore
that are coming from stoic philosophy
and she's doing an excellent job in
connecting the dots so to speak among
the the stoic tech she also is drawing
heavily
on texts by people who are not stoics
but are responding to stoics and through
whom we we learn quite a bit about the
stoics like cicero who's pretty
receptive to them or galen who tends to
think that chrysippus and the other
stoics got some things fundamentally
wrong and there's others along the way
plutarch as well
so all told i am pretty happy with with
getting this copy i think you can tell
by my enthusiasm in here this is a cool
thing to have
my own copy of i've only seen it in
hardback before i kind of like having it
in soft cover it's got that nice
new
soft cover feel to it and a beautiful
cover design as well so i'll stop
talking here
if you're into these kind of books you
might want to get your hands on it if
not well at least you heard a good story
about me unboxing a book i was looking
forward to
you